yesterday Mario brought a couple people
here one of the kids was talking to me
hi how are you sir so I love your work
you do the guy is 12 years old I said
why are you so confident he says what do
you mean mom and dad are standing right
so why do you talk so eloquently and
confidently it's not normal for a 12
year old to talk like this well sir I'm
a very confident young man
I said hello I want to tell you I said I
hope you thank your mom and dad for
raising you this way because this is not
common to this is not common to be
disrespectful discount confident as
you're at 12 I hope when you leave this
place you say thank you to Mom and Dad
because without your mom and dad you
wouldn't be the way you are right now
and I looked at the parents in front of
the kid and I said I salute you I salute
you and I thank both of you for being
great parents we ought to recognize
great parents and we ought to call out
bad parents